thank you so thank you again to the
workshop organizers for inviting me I'll
talk about risk of a selfish routing and
most of the results Adel presenter with
two wonderful collaborators vanassa's
leonesse was my postdoc at UT Austin now
back in Greece and Niko's dear Moses and
this work was motivated by questions
like this so I'm driving between Simons
and let's say Palo Alto some of us in
the audience some of you in the audience
maybe are doing this drive and you want
to know how long it will take so you can
budget your when to depart when when you
will arrive here in this is a snapshot
that I did between the same source
destination pair at noon so about one
hour and then I tried it again at 4:00
p.m. on a given date well it increased
to one and a half words roughly and one
so you see there is variability in
travel time so I don't need to convince
anyone of that everyone has experienced
it but furthermore you cannot even trust
those predictions because when I did
this commute a few weeks ago I started I
departed Palo Alto at 4:00 p.m. and at
that time I was told by Google it will
the journey will take me one hour but by
the time I reached here it was around
5:00 p.m. so traffic conditions changed
and all of a sudden if one eye were
turned to one-and-a-half hours among men
so travel times are uncertain and you
have to budget for that so when you have
a time sensitive destination deadline
type that you need to get to so I don't
like to be late for appointments and I
like to budget extra over the average
travel time and this here tells me on
how much the people may need to budget
for their trip so this is a plot of the
travel time index and planning time
index by the Texas Transportation
Institute which says let's have a unit
here corresponds to a
the duration of a trip the blue is the
average travel time so naturally travel
time increases during rush hour but the
red is how much extra need to buffer to
make sure I'm not late so it gives me
95% my destination on time and this red
the planning time index how much I
really need to budget for my trip is
more than twice the free flow time how
much I would drive if there were no
congestion on the roads so motivated by
that so me being risk-averse because I
like to be on time I need to make
routing choices that take this certainty
into consideration in particular I may
prefer maybe more roundabout routes that
have longer expected travel time but
smaller variants for example there are
many ways to trade off mean and variance
and to incorporate certainty but the
goal of this work is to understand the
effect of risk-averse driver behavior on
the resulting traffic congestion by
studying the traffic assignment results
in particular taking into account that
the certainty will influence your
decisions so we want to understand what
is the resulting equilibrium so I
postulated when people select individual
optimal routes that results into
equilibrium whether the properties of
the people equilibrium and then we ask
another question we define this concept
of price the risk aversion without
defined more formally later but
basically it's the price that society
has to pain increase overall travel time
when individuals make risk-averse
routing decisions so how do we
understand traffic congestion traffic
congestion the multiple ways one nice
way theoretically to measure it is
through this concept of price of energy
that will give a very nice introduction
of in the first talk today and price of
energy is this
quantification measures the degradation
of system performance due to selfish
behavior of free will specifically it
measures how much larger the cost of
equilibrium is to the cost of social
optimum meaning if people make selfish
marketing decisions in the traffic
pattern is an equilibrium one versus the
central planner out everyone tells
everyone which routes to take so as to
minimize the total travel time less the
social optimum cost or how much larger
travel time when people experience if
they make selfish routing decisions and
buy now a classic result is that in this
price of energy sports in general graphs
if you have travel times with there are
linear functions the traffic and where
other constants for more general latency
or travel time function the result due
to rough garden and corridors and
subsequently also very nice proof given
by Korea's open here Moses and just to
show you why where the fourth earth
comes from in a simple example if you
here the choice of two routes from s to
T and you get to Route one you need to
flow house driver is something like that
this one you need to flow would maybe
splits flow X on the top and flow 1
minus X on the bottom so X is something
between 0 and 1 and let's say that we
model the congestion like take the
travel times there's a function of
traffic by saying that the travel time
on top of X the more people choose the
top of the world
of them will travel where is on the
bottom is constant it's always one hour
so what would be the equilibrium traffic
pattern it is very simple example it
will be for every single driver every
single unit of this one unit every
single particle of this one unit as well
we chose to go because X is equal to one
so everyone will experience less than or
travel-time going on top so the
equilibrium will route the entire unit
of traffic on the top with which
resulting everyone traveling one hour
time is one hour however if you were a
central planner and wanted to minimize
the total travel time it's a very simple
derivation to see that you would
actually want to split the trafficking
in half until half of the drivers to
route on the top and the drivers
throughout on the bottom because under
this traffic allocation the half drivers
on top will each experience half hour of
travel time the ones on the bottom so
the average of those or the total travel
time will be three over four so this is
less and this is the social optimum
traffic assignment again it's a very
simple derivation that you can do and
therefore the price of Anarchy which
remember is the equilibrium cost divided
by the social optimum cost 1 divided by
3/4 is 4 over 3 and so amazingly we see
already the worst case is a very simple
example but this worst case for over
three holes for completely general
networks waiver as I mentioned travel
time is uncertain so people we want to
take into account we saw certainty and
if they make risk-averse routing
decisions the main methods here is that
this may result in a very different in
particular we took earlier work with
Giorgio speleothems if Shama we consider
the particular model level certainty and
our goal was really to understand
different risk-averse profile so
different objectives given by the
different names
what was the resulting functions and you
see that the price of energy can vary
widely between 4/3 and bounded infinity
so if you want to understand the effect
of
selfishness and risk aversion on top of
it on the resulting traffic pattern risk
the model of risk critically affects
that the prediction and it really needs
to be taken into account to better
understand the system performance let me
play some of the working in context
surrounding games which is the model
that I'm using here has been studied for
a long time both without certainty and
widow certainty although looking from
this angle of risk-averse routing
behavior is a fairly new trend with
still few but now growing set of paper
I'll present zoom into one particular
model that we considered so we have a
directed graph and let's say we have a
unique source and destination parent
everyone wants to go from s to T and we
consider a
non-atomic player this is good jargon
for a flow model each its player small
so a change in individual players route
does not affect traffic conditions that
the others see and so the question is
how to route that flow through through
the network the different feasible SD
paths we can encode the resulting
routing choices in a vector so this is
just a vector over all possible SD paths
then each coordinate here corresponds to
a path which tells you how many users
chose the particular out so we want to
capture two things the congestion
effectively uncertainty the congestion
effect is captured in the traditional
way so this is the thing that is the
travel time or the rate function or
latency function as a function of X T
the flow energy or how many users go on
HD and this here is some noise model the
uncertainty now the question is how the
players routes
given this certain travel times on edges
there are many ways
risk aversion but for this model we
motivated by the picture that I showed
you initially the planning time index
where you have to add buffer to your
average travel time
what buffer could we add some natural
choices our standard deviation or the
variance there the protocols with both
and I'm happy to discuss those later but
for now let's say this makes it perhaps
much more sensible because many standard
deviations are measured in the same time
units mean and variance some people from
it but let's say that we wanted to study
that also because it's mathematically
and more convenient no if you were
filming we'd were film independent
travel times on its edge then the
variance of a path is simply the sum of
variances edges along that path so that
the cost of a path means various cost
nicely B composes into a sum of costs
over the edges so we consider those two
risk-averse functions in this particular
model and we wanted to understand the
equilibrium so how do i define
equilibrium formally so again remember
that users want to select minimum risk
about where risk I mean in this case the
mean standard deviation of the mean
variance of a task and we say that the
flow the resulting traffic pattern is in
equilibrium whenever users route along
the shortest or minimum risk paths and
we will call this the risk-averse
risk-averse equilibrium when the when
they minimize the travel the minimum
risk of a path given by the mean
standard deviation or or mean variance
and I will at some point later want to
contrast it with the risk neutral
neutral equilibrium where drivers don't
care about the variability so they
simply want to minimize the expected
travel time
question you're assuming that people
trade off expected delay invariance
everyone plates of the same thing
excellent question and I'll revisit that
at the very end but yes I do assume that
here so the way they trade it off is
with this coefficient R this is how much
importers they are tributes to the so
risk-neutral person would set R equal to
0 so that means that they simply want to
minimize the average travel time so here
this arrow is really the average travel
whereas more and more risk-averse people
will get higher and higher hours they'll
have larger and larger buffers that they
add so yes here everyone is homogeneous
everyone has the same hour and I'll call
these are the risk averse parameter so
here is in our initial investigation
here is what we saw the weather
equilibrium exists or doesn't really
depends on the specifics of the model in
particular if this uncertainty depends
on on the flower dozen and whether the
model is non atomic or atomic meaning a
simile small data flow model this is a
discrete model where users begin up so
that a single user changing route travel
times that other users see so in all
these cases we have a different one that
either solve the convex program but
exponentially large or a potential game
in this case if we don't even know how
to compute a German does not exist and
focusing on this column here when the
uncertainty does not depend on the flow
in the network we were able to show that
the price of energy with users is the
same with the price of energy in the
corresponding deterministic game in the
classic model yeah there's another
excellent question
in this theorem we may so till now I
didn't really talk about
social welfare it was all about
equilibrium this is the first time this
comes up and in in this theorem social
welfare is the sum of user costs it
would be the sum of the mean so I
measure it as the mean and standard
deviation are not random right they the
channel time experience may be random
but they make their choice based on the
mean standard deviation or mean and
variance and I take the summation over
this mean variance path costs and this
is the social welfare in this case but
I'll change in the next slides okay so
here when we show this theorem we
realize that this term doesn't give us
much insight into how much exactly of
the price of energy is attributed to
selfish behavior how much of it is
attributed to risk aversion so we
couldn't really understand the effect of
risk aversion itself which is why we
changed from price of energy type
analysis to a different one that I'll
define next in order to decouple those
two effects of selfishness in risk
aversion so here is where I change the
definition of social welfare so we
define this concept of price of risk
aversion which is informally how much
more users travel how much more society
pays in increase total travel time due
to shouting choices and this is the
ratio of the cost of a risk-averse
equilibrium to the cost of risk neutral
equilibrium and by cost here I only
consider the sum of expected travel
times so now I buffer that individuals
ready for their risk for their outing
choice in the in the social cost one way
to think of it is that the central
planner is perhaps risk neutral
about long-term averages and this is
what they want to minimize and so they
will will measure the cost of any flow
is just the sum of expected travel times
the first term that mean mean variance
cost and from here on for the next few
slides I will just think of risk
aversion is the mean variance objective
function so users want to minimize the
mean plus variance of a path in again
another motivation for for this cost is
that we somehow want to have the same
benchmark for Libya if we had the
variance term included here but not here
it's like comparing up all the Knology
so that wouldn't be very meaningful and
so really the question is in expectation
how much more risk-averse
users travel there to risk neutral users
so we want to understand how how much
more risk-averse users travel and again
to give to give an insight let's revisit
that example I showed before but now
with uncertainty and variance in
incorporating so again we want to find
one unit that would split let's say X on
top and 1 minus X on the bottom and now
those two links are characterized by
mean and variance pairs given as follows
so here the mean is here the mean and
variance are constant one is some and on
top we use this case so we say the mean
is 1 plus R K times 0 variance so
risk-averse users risk-averse users
don't like the variance here and one can
see that if if a user if a risk-averse
user wanted to minimize 1 plus remember
my risk averse coefficient so if I
wanted to minimize 1 plus RK so I
compare 1 plus RK on the bottom and 1
plus RT so all the risk-averse users go
the link with variance and so the cost
of the experience expert over world so
all of them will experience an average
cost amount was arcane risk neutral
users on the other hand do not care
about the variance term they only seek
to minimize the mean and in risk neutral
equilibrium the flow will be such that
both the top and the bottom will hear
mean one and so on so we see that the
risk versus a quill users will travel
that much more the price of risk
aversion the ratio of these two is 1
plus RK imagine a reminder our was my
coefficient of risk aversion and K here
was just some arbitrary constants that I
said my various to be so this is now bad
news because if I said in this example
to be very very large that means that
risk of refuges would make travel
infinitely more time than risk neutral
users and it's not somehow a very
meaningful results but it is in practice
we could argue that the variance is not
arbitrarily larger than than the mean
and so if we consider bounded various to
mean ratios then we want to compute the
price of excursions for this fixed K
this is what I'm going to do so again
remember if I don't fix anything
no not very meaningful and doesn't give
much insight but when I fix K how much
more the variance can be relative to the
mean then we studied how this price the
risk aversion changes as a function of
the result that we obtained was that in
a general graph the price of risk
aversion
so remember that in the simple two
linked example that I showed you it was
wonderful RK and in general it is 1 plus
R theta where theta is is the parameter
of the topology of the network which is
something that we don't understand very
well is the in in a alternating path
that's a path it may have forward and
backward edges and it will be the number
of forward path how many such so what's
a path we have so in particular for
series parallel networks we would have
that this eta is 1 so the price of risk
aversion is 1 plus RK the same with what
we saw on the simple example of two
parallel links on the brace graph an
alternating path such as this one over
here has two alternations and so it is
you know more complicated networks it
can be as large as because you could
have a path which alternates possible
vertex and changes direction at every
vertex and so this seems like a very bad
quantity right the number of nodes in
the graph well we showed this bound this
tight before I go to the tightness this
is a brief intuition of how we showed
the result so in a general graph the
proof idea is first of all to show that
there is alternating path that
alternates between forward and backward
edges which which is a very specific
property the property that the forward
edges have more whereas the backward
edges have more risk-averse equilibria
flow once we show the existence of such
a path then comparing the two equilibria
in the risk-neutral equilibria then
suffice it to compare each of them
individually to date alternating path
and knowing the direction with which
flow is higher risk averse Taurus
neutral we can we can rewrite the bound
so this is the main insight in the proof
and now we show that this bound is tight
by inductively defining a graphs a
medium graphs starting from the brace
graph here showing that for this graph
there exists latency functions which
which attain that worst case bound and
then for graphs of bigger and bigger
size we basically take the graph in the
previous stage and put two copies of
that graph and then connect the two
copies in a brace like manner and so
then we take this next graph put two
copies of that graph and so this is the
really the height bound and again to
recap this price of risk aversion which
was simply the ratio of the cost of
risk-averse equilibria Dorris neutral
equilibrium is 1 plus 8 RK where eta is
this topology parameter R is the
coefficient of risk aversion in K with
mean ratio we were also subsequently
able to show a bound which is closer in
spirit with the traditional price of
energy bounds which is not with respect
to the network topology but with respect
to the latency function classes and so
basically we can eliminate this set of
parameter but then we will need to
multiply by the corresponding price of
energy in the game with without any
uncertainty so this results again work
for the very specific risk attitude
where every user wanted to minimize the
mean class
and it's open to extent we trying to
extend this to me no standard deviation
but the standard deviation is
mathematically so much more complicated
that it's been a nightmare to work with
so in any case it's open to extend this
type of bound to other risk attitudes
but now I want to revisit the question
of what happens when this risk averse
coefficient is actually different we
asked a question motivated by these risk
averse routing but it really can be
phrased in a in a more general way so if
users have to trade off to function for
example delay and they have this what I
call before the risk averse parameter
this trade-off parameter between those
two criteria that they care about what
if this parameter this trait of
parameter of the two criteria the class
of users I would have alpha I with the
different alpha and so on we wondered
whether well how much or diversity of
user preferences would help reduce the
cost of the equilibrium where again the
cost of equilibria mister it's the sum
of just this criterion the same as
before and so we showed maybe to our
surprise somehow we wanted to to prove
consistent with the general idea that
diversity helps it somehow they were
always helped but it turned out it only
helps in certain networks we showed that
diversity all always helps if and only
if the network is series parallel if the
network that does not contain this
so it's somehow a limited class of
graphs in all the other graphs we have
come to examples
where they were sitting actually hurtin
the cost of the equilibrium increases
and this is for a single origin
destination pair for multiple origin
destinations we show that it generalizes
to type of network that we call block
matching networks which is you can think
of still had an extension of series
parallel for multiple source destination
pairs and just to summarize so the
general goal of my research has been to
develop a toolkit both algorithms and
game theory techniques that enable were
understanding and of how to do with
mitigation in networks and I've touched
on just a few problems but there are
many open problems in in all these areas
algorithm game theory mechanism design
with a lot of opportunities for impact
in transportation in other applications
of smart grid communications and so on
thank you very much
[Applause]
you said that the situation with
unbounded Barrios is not meaningful
isn't it the case that just corresponds
to unbounded uncertainty about the
unboundedness is relative to the average
on that particular out so what I said is
if you give in fact not even an entire
out one link and for this link you
measure the average travel time and then
the variance of this travel time I said
that in practice it may make sense to
say that the variance is not much larger
than than the average and now you say
well maybe we were in a situation but
then that's a different situation that I
clearly address for this model because
here I assume that I I know the mean and
variance so somehow I assume that I have
traffic data that gives me what variance
is because if I did not know various I
couldn't do any of these optimizations
there's there's some quantity some
variance which maximizes the price of
risk aversion I mean if the variance is
0 if you have perfect knowledge about
how long it's going to take on all
routes then the price of this conversion
is also 0 I mean the way I define but
yes traffic conditions
then you might as well choose a route at
random in which case there's also no
price for risk aversion every month
which implies there must be a point that
maximizes this price no interesting
question but I'll just I'll just remind
if the price of extraversion does not
inform users individual users how to
choose their route yes not that
unbounded price of risk aversion means
that I should choose my route at random
so maybe we should take this offline
[Applause]